кілочки робити з донецька будь-якого
його нині волонтеру в центрі допомоги про
посилаємося виїхала в донбас ще 2014 він
стане 9 місяців з чотирма дітьми та
людиною машка і спливти і робота найму
і
їжі в дусі праці не мало зарплат
няче логіка у нас лише частина про
крім нього криму вати 2400 гривень
державної компенсації на оренду житла
ла вручені виплачувати шлют угу
лише в мене чоловік і на кожну людину
інвалід 3 групи дурич на пенсію
ранковою зараз причиною невиплат коханням
немає виду малий про такі karasev
перевіряла чудове та руди на машка та
замовлено адресу
виду сцені та перевірки сац інспектор кіно
про дні виді студита їжу бабусі кохання та
дасин і чоловіка love to the sea
вона мені відповіла на money with вавила
що ми на моє право вигляд ось цієї
деталь я весь друк перевіркою кого з
важкий і не буду в будинку вона любить
виплату мов так і закон завчіть нам і
дано мій вид початку руку 400 тисяч
переселенців на ранок та пенсію
соцвиплат у ready ви знаєте на ціни
dash дірі pets то ви так
професійний руку від може статей на
достовірної інформації вид право зберігати
і про що точніше вміщено особливо
мишкою на купоні території
взаємовигляд носа щодо соціальних
виплат внутрішнім переміщеним особам
небули в регулюванні норм готель в
органи соціального ставлення
соціальних виплат хоча юридичних
постав єгипті доп тепло прописано
абсолютно не був у черв'яка Ніна була дружина
стінного пусто нола
рішення щодо 100 з виплатою пенсій
dp.ru хвалять седоку нести почали скажемо
а
та заступником мера вона україна інспектор
петельки у злочинності поселенців
проте прорватися їх людей поважає
фламандські активісти і дали пару шиються
630m а постанова правило дата ваші люди
у завалі у витратах будете романські права
і доручається constitute a наймає права
від римати і соціальні виплати на
зональних умовах довжини їх крім дадуть
кави розуму ви на rosie
цього звуку в гаю процедура
ідентифікації куди бачите пройти за раді
їх усередині мене волонтер будь-якому поважає
куля нову порцію просування в нозі
знаєте і відбійні та проукраїнська
позиція в 2014 у нього давно повернуло
сяду видному давайте-но